♪
>> Don't get it removed.
>>OK. I won't.
>> Maybe make some edits that
would be funny.
Yeah like I shouldn't have
the word anxiety tattooed on my
>>No, you should have that word.
>>body.
the whole gist of this
is to protect me from anxiety.
You were the most anxious
person-
>>I know
>>This has not done anything to
>>serve you.
>>Zero.
>> What's up everybody
I'm Chris Ebb and Flow
Distefano with my guest
Nicky the razor Glazer.
And you can listen to her every
day on Comedy Central radio
>>or on her show You Up?
>>on Sirius.
And this is Stupid Questions
with Chris Distefano
>>Yeah!
>>yeah!
Ready for
some stupid questions.
>> Probably like behind my ears
so that no one would see them
you know like as a sneaky place
to get a tattoo just for me.
>> Do you think like it
would still be like a turn
onto someone to suck
your nipples behind your ear.
Yeah and I can just
sit there all day
>>and just play with my nipples
>>and just milk you ears?
Yeah.
>> Yeah I would do that.
>>Oh poop that tastes like ice
cream
>>100 percent?
>>100 percent.
You just want to eat flavored
poop.
and I would close my eyes
when I did it.
>> so it would only be the taste
Why would anyone want ice cream
that tastes like shit.
>> There was a girl
who we grew up with
and somebody had poop
like little nibbles
of their poop in ice cream
and she thought it was
rocky road ice cream
she was like this rocky road is
so good so I called her rocky
road for a while
and like yea, i know its
horrifying.
she was trying to be like, cool,
and eat the ice cream
that they are giving her
she's just playing along.
>> And then she suffers
the rest of her life.
>> There's always some girl
that does something with shit
and then it follows her
for she's like
the most beautiful person
and like such beautiful
when she was like
has like married with kids now
but like still like my friends
like yo rocky road got married.
It's like oh boy.
Here's another stupid question
Because I got my daughter
a piglet and you know
I didn't run it by her mom
and just showed up at the house
with a pig for she was nuts.
This is why
we're not together anymore.
You didn't ask her Mom
if you could get a pig?
I legit showed up to my
daughter's birthday party
at her mom's house
with a pig. do you have a
backyard?
No I live in New York
but what about
when you go back to St. Louis.
>Do you have like a therapy pig?
>Okay, yea give me a pig
just for when I go back
for Christmas.
And then what do I do with it?
I know what you get
for Christmas gifts.
These questions
like stupid enough
what are they really
so stupid I hate.
>> Oh good.
>> If you could talk
to like 18 year olds
I wish I could talk
to 18 year old.
No external vagina.
Oh wow.
What would you talk to it about
like what would it's
just so much to my vagina.
>> Oh here's the thing Chris.
I didn't see any vaginas
that looked like mine and porn.
I felt like a young black girl
watching Disney movies like
where's the one with me in it
that I was a virgin till was 21
because I thought
that like my vagina
was like not good enough right.
And it's definitely good.
I got drunk and hooked up
and I've never had a complaint.
If anything people
are going to want to write
Yelp reviews about it yet.
>> So that's why I would say
it's like just start
hooking up now.
18 year old Nikki because
you get prime pussy right now
and you don't even know
what you are post.
Double pay double pay.
>> I want to ask you.
Oh that's great what is.
Don't make them too stupid
or you steal the show.
Are actually good.
Yeah I know like you something
different. There we go.
What is the most embarrassing
thing you've ever done drunk.
Oh you know what I did
once when I was drunk.
I've got like wasted
I was like maybe like 19
and I took a crap in my friends
hamper that put his
clothes dirty clothes
back into the hamper.
Yeah. Membered doing.
I do and it was like
really funny
and like he was like
a third degree black belt
and we were like friends.
Some of them were friend
were you like
shitting your hamburger.
Ah no Proser he like
called somebody like
and was like who.
Took a shit.
>> My hamper last night
and everyone was like it
was to Stefano
and then he called me
like back then
and it's like if I see him
in the park your dog your dog.
So you just met him
at the mall. Yeah.
All right well those those
are Nuki stupid questions.
Yeah maybe you like mine better.
Yes.
Okay so I got you get
upset they're stupid
but I'm for the first year.
You know what I mean
you've probably seen
this get gotten skipped
already because the name
is making Glazebrook
and I think again.
How did you put on the show
had so much fun with you.
So your connection here.
Yeah. Are you feeling good.
Yeah. All right good.
We're going to Kapos
shows the rest of our lives.
>> I was still the data right.
>> Well that's been
stupid questions.
I'm pretty sure
this is Nikki Glaser.